dans l'actualité ce soir l'euphorie et
la cohue de retour dans leur collège les
élèves acteurs de la palme d'or ont été
fêtés comme des vedettes les cours
reprennent demain pour tout le monde
nicolas sarkozy veut pousser les
entreprises à relancer le pouvoir
d'achat il annonce des crédits d'impôt
pour favoriser l'intéressement et des
sanctions financières contre celle qui
ne négocie pas les salaires est ce
possible est ce souhaitable
invité ce soir laurence parisot
présidente du medef en soirée à tout à
l'heure
faut-il gracié jean charles marchiani
héros pour les un escroc pour la justice
l'artisan de la libération des otages au
liban dans les années 80 s'est constitué
prisonnier à paris il est condamné à de
la prison ferme pour corruption
la chine regrette à nouveau le bilan du
séisme à la hausse 88 mille morts ou
disparus dans ce journal reportage avec
les secours français qui ont commencé
leur travail le succès de la mission
américaine phoenix la sonde s'est posé
en douceur près du pôle nord de la
planète marx objectif prélever de la
glace et pourquoi pas trouver des traces
d'une vie passée enfin le tennis petite
journée à roland garros en raison de la
pluie ça passe pour les principaux
favoris ça casse pour richard gasquet
forfait pour cause de blessure
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous d'abord donc
la belle histoire du jour celle d'un
collège de zep qui se réveille avec une
palme d'or les 24 adolescents primé à
cannes hier pour le film entre les murs
sont revenus je vous le disais dans
leurs établissements de l'est de paris
le récit de ces 24 heures totalement
inattendu avec toutes nos équipes loïc
de la mornais guillaume michel
c'est un étrange car de ramassage
scolaire une folle rentrée des classes
ce n'est pas non plus monsieur le
principal qui reçoit les palmes
académiques
c'est bien une palme d'or qui
atterrissent antilles égard dans cette
rue du 20e arrondissement
dans la cour les professeurs acteurs ne
signe plus de bulletins de notes mais
des autos brasse
les salles de classe se transforme en
podium de photocall pour la presse
seules les 24 jeunes acteurs sont
officiellement dispensés de cours
aujourd'hui peine perdue le collège
entier s'arrête et virevolte en état de
grâce
sinon pas du cirque
éducateur et élèves se retrouvent comme
en famille comme entre potes le film
fait tomber toutes les hiérarchies
ses chaleureuses si c'est un truc
extraordinaire chez j pas parfois c'est
maintenant au pied gauche encore dany
dans les mines chinoises enfin on les
montre sous un autre angle moins de
français les élèves dans leurs
potentiels qui peuvent jouer qui peuvent
s'exprimer qui peut faire partie d'un
projet s'y tenir donc moi je trouve
cette
situation incongrue pour ses parents que
de venir chercher à l'école leur simple
gamin qu'une traînée de poudre
médiatique a transformé en héros
alors ça va péter long message se réfère
à retrouver mais non à ces motifs
j'arrêtais pas de perdre et tout à
l'heure au début je ne voulais pas
passer
le fath le pays début mai heureusement
que j'ai accepté parce qu'il l'a pu me
convainc préféré faire ce film
heureusement parce que s'il n'avait pas
joué au film j'allais avec des
thématiques ma bulle c'est pas nous qui
sont célèbres et collective telle
collecte de mou la réputation
de notre
r&d tout c'est même à mon regard
ils reviennent entre rêve et réalité
des souvenirs plein la tête
et des étoiles dans les yeux
retour sur un week end qui a changé leur
vie
samedi dernier dans quelques instants la
petite troupe va monter les marches pour
la présentation du film sélectionné à la
dernière minute
regardez
incroyable montée de tapis rouge cet
après midi là pour ces jeunes qui
pensent vivre à cet instant le sommet de
l' aventure
le dimanche matin alors que les
collégiens sont déjà repartis pour paris
un coup de fil leur indique de faire
demi tour
on nous a dit raymond très classe et
puis on était tous fatigués comme ça
avec des petites mines puis tout d'un
coup tout le monde a eu la pêche et tout
premier indice que peu d'enfants
décrypte les motards officiels viennent
d'escorté leur car
dans un film oui mais en réalité je vous
hais
à ce moment là leur réalisateur pense
qu'ils ont un prix spécial un prix
d'interprétation collectif qui serait
spécialement créé pour eux
la salle du palais des festivals est
immense intimidante surtout quand c'est
monsieur robert de niro qui passe la
parole complice au président du jury
des choses à chaque année une
deuxième décision unanime et
film
c'est sur scène avec un bonheur enfantin
ces gamins d'un collège de zep ne semble
même pas réalisé que derrière eux
soutiennent romane polanski benicio del
toro ou encore milla jovovich edouard
baer et sean penn
aujourd'hui à paris ces stars d'un soir
et d'une vie ont donné des idées à leurs
camarades ou leur petit frère
mais déjà là je me sens très dense
et hier comme toutes les stars ils ont
fait la fête dans la folie des nuits
cannoises
voilà mais les cours reprendront demain
pour tout le monde il ya bientôt le
brevet a préparé quelques mots et
quelques images maintenant du film
lui-même que vous découvrirez bientôt de
quoi s'agit-il on parle beaucoup de
l'école et de ses difficultés et bien
c'est l'histoire d'une classe au
quotidien qui est proposé sans angélisme
ni dramatisation marie-jo jouant michael
cariou vous bougez pas ces 25 élèves du
collège françoise dolto ont tous dans le
film de laurent cantet des rôles de
composition écrit pour eux entre les
murs est une oeuvre de fiction racontant
l'année scolaire d'une classe de 4e pas
un documentaire même s'il puise dans le
roman éponyme de françois bégaudeau
récit de son expérience d'ancienne
enseignants à l'évent manar jeudi aurait
fallu que je sois fussent le prof de
français de films cellule à ça mais non
c'est pas dans le moyen classe au cours
de récréation reste à l'intérieur des
murs une caisse de résonance de la
résister ici pas de clichés car le
rencontrer un objectif de passer par
manque en même temps c'était d'étriller
de ne pas l'être dans l'exemplarité
voilà on va pas essayer le dieu ce
qu'est l'école on va montrer ce qui peut
se passer dans une classe donnée les
situations que peut rencontrer un
professeur avec ses élèves y compris les
confie
françois te prends pas la tête quoi sont
avec moi nous parlons là le film
j'aimerais bien qu'il soit vu comme un
film comme une comédie dramatique qu'on
rit on pleure qu'on y voit des jeunes
qu'on entende de la langue si ce que tu
as à dire n'est pas plus important que
le silence alors tais toi sous les 26
seulement tu pouvais écrire des choses
aussi intéressantes sur ta phut sur ton
bras ça serait extraordinaire et vous
seriez trop mais un truc de ouf ce film
là ne peut que rassembler autour du
sujet particulièrement sensible de
l'école au marché du film du festival
entre les murs a été le film français le
plus vendu à l'étranger voilà sorti le
15 octobre c'est aussi un succès
rappelons le pour france 2 producteur de
ce film dans lequel chacun trouve
d'ailleurs son compte le ministre de
l'éducation xavier darcos parle d'un
très bel hommage aux enseignants et à
leurs conditions de travail parfois
difficile jack lang lui estime que ce
film tombe à point au moment où le
gouvernement m6 peu l'école fin de
citation et les enseignants eux mêmes
qu'en pense-t-il nous l'avons demandé à
ceux du collège concerné qui ont pu le
voir en avant première voici leurs
commentaires
quand je dis que je suis professeur
quand mes collègues disent qu'ils sont
professeurs on arrête de les regarder en
ma pauvre comme c'est bien tu fais un
métier vraiment dit cela
on voit que c'est peut-être un métier
parfois difficile mais c'est un métier
qui nous comble c'est un métier qu'on
adore on n'est pas tous ceux des pauvres
eux héros pathétique qui supporte des
élèves à moitié un bêtisier ce convoi
jusqu'à présent quand on doit décrite
sur l'école mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
jours où c'est le plus dur que d'autres
et pour pour la france entière et pour
l'extérieur de montrer ce qui se passe
vraiment au coeur d'une place personne à
faire baisser ces traits je pense qu'il
ya des moments de nous toi sûr mais
c'est ce qui se passe vraiment quand
même voix qui porte à elle très
important de
voilà des passionnés des postes et de la
santé le nombre de surveillants
dans toute la france
voilà propos recueillis par évelyne
goldman est très d'eric de la rue voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire sur cette palme
d'or et ses suites autres titres de
l'actualité ce nouveau déplacement de
nicolas sarkozy cette fois dans l'oise
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat le
président de la république cherche des
leviers il pense en avoir trouvé dans
l'entreprise c'est un peu la carotte et
le bâton il annonce des encouragements
fiscaux pour développer l'intéressement
et al'inverse une diminution des
allègements de charges pour les patrons
qui refusent de négocier les salaires
sur place alexandre kara rien roussel
une usine dans l'oise entre ouvriers et
chaînes de montage c'est le décor choisi
par nicolas sarkozy pour retrouver des
accents gaullistes à l'avenir les
entreprises qui ne joueront pas le jeu
des négociations salariales seront
sanctionnées les entreprises qui ne
respecteront pas cette obligation
est bien le verront leurs allègements de
charges diminuent de 10% pourquoi l'état
paye 21 milliards d'euros d'allègements
de charges chaque année ça lui donne
quand même un petit droit à donner sur
l'opinion sur un certain nombre de
choses
10 et l'achat de ma maison
les dernières
nation réconciliée capital et travail
voici le nouveau slogan de nicolas
sarkozy et pour l'accompagner sa
nouvelle arme pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat l'intéressement mon objectif
c'est les sommes distribuées par les
entreprises aux salariés augmente de 20%
par an
cela veut dire un doublement en quatre
ans et là encore ce sera la carotte et
le bâton pour les entreprises vertueuses
il y aura un crédit d'impôt de 20% et si
certaines renâcle nicolas sarkozy menace
dès 2010 une loi pourrait obliger les
pme qui n'ont pas conclu d'accord à
partager leurs bénéfices avec leurs
salariés certains syndicats s'alarment
l'intéressement oui mais pas au
détriment des salaires tels les
entreprises qui vont faire des bénéfices
vont pouvoir payer l'intéressement entre
elles en font pas eh bien il est rapide
intéressement de te voir là ça va être
beaucoup plus variables d'une façon
générale l'autre mesure phare de ce
projet le déblocage immédiat de la
participation dans les entreprises
nicolas sarkozy veut aller vite selon
lui la reconquête de l'opinion face
d'abord est forcément par le pouvoir
d'achat
alors on s'arrête un instant sur l'une
de ces mesures qui retient l'attention
diminuer les allègements de charge de 10
% pour les entreprises qui ne négocie
pas les salaires c'est une sévère mise
en demeure mais est-ce un effet
d'annonce ou est ce faisable bonsoir
laurence parisot la présidente du medef
vous y croyez c'est possible mais
surtout près de 90% des entreprises en
france négocie annuellement avec les
représentants du personnel avec les
délégués syndicaux
la situation des salaires dans
l'entreprise
donc c'est un effet d'annonce d'après
vous donc juste que c'est une bonne idée
de faire en sorte que des 10 ou 15 %
qu'ils ne le font pas encore soit
incité à le faire moi je suis favorable
à les changes à la négociation à la
conclusion d'accords avec les
organisations syndicales que ce soit au
niveau national ou au niveau le plus
décentralisée qu'il soit c'est à dire
l'entreprise mais alors je prends votre
cas vous êtes toujours présidente de
l'ifop est ce que ça vous choque quoi
est-ce que ça vous convient si on dit on
va venir voir si vous négociez avec les
salariés avec les syndicats et si vous
ne le faites pas sur les salaires eh
bien on vous retirera des allées chaque
année il y à négociations sur les
salaires et il est dans la loi de faire
état à la direction du travail de ce qui
a été conclu dans cette négociation donc
effectivement le gouvernement a le moyen
de repérer là où il y à des négociations
et là où il n'y en a pas mais ce match
était comme une intrusion dans la vie de
l'entreprise ou est ce que vous dites
finalement c'est normal ça concerne
toujours ce point en particulier je
trouve que c'est normal et moi je trouve
bien que tout le monde s'y met si
certains ne l'ont pas encore fait ou ont
été
empêchés ou n'ont pas osé le faire les
entreprises sont trop chiche
actuellement sur les semailles remake
mais je répète ce que je vous ai dit
presque neuf entreprises sur dix 11,7
négociations et la plupart arrivent à
des accords avec leurs représentants du
personnel le vrai enjeu sur le pouvoir
d'achat je le rappelle il n'est pas là
le vrai enjeu vous savez un chef
d'entreprise s'il a des marges de
manoeuvre il sera content de se dire je
peux investir et je peux donner une
rémunération à mes équipes qui ont su
faire
développer mon entretien vous dit le
vent je sens que c'est la croissance le
vrai enjeu c'est donner plus de liberté
plus de souplesse et au réalisme était à
nouveau à la mode et je suis ravi de ça
j'étais la première à dire soyons à
nouveau libero et ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire effectivement que tout soit
négocié discuté entre partenaires
sociaux d'un mot les salaires sont
aujourd'hui assez élevé en france dans
le privé mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
assez élevé est-ce que surtout les
entreprises ont tous les moyens de la
compétitivité dans la grande compétition
mondiale que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui moi je dis que nous parfois
les salaires ne sont pas assez élevés
pour beaucoup de familles pour pouvoir
avoir accès à une consommation moderne
je ne souhaite qu'une chose c'est de
créer un environnement économique qui
nous permette à nous les chefs
d'entreprise d'avoir plus de marge de
manoeuvre dit il ya une autre nouvelle
très importante aujourd'hui c'est
l'encouragement à l'intéressement moi je
voudrais vous dire que nous le medef
nous sommes très moteur sur cette
question on a même un guide qui dit
comment associer mes salariés à la
performance de mon entreprise l'acd vrai
projet d'entreprise gagnant gagnant
entre chefs d'entreprise et les salariés
merci laurence parisot d'avoir répondu à
nos questions de la grève des pêcheurs
premières informations le prix des
carburants et donc du fuel a battu un
nouveau record en moyenne en france le
fuel qui passent le seuil d'un euro le
litre le mouvement des marins persiste
même s'ils sont divisés que le travail a
repris ici et là images ici de sète où
des opérations étaient menées dans des
supermarchés pour retirer des rayons les
poissons importés ou issus de l'élevage
sur la côte de la manche cette fois
boulogne les représentants d'une dizaine
de villes ont voté pour le blocage des
ports pendant 48 heures les conséquences
se font sentir pour le consommateur à
marseille les mareyeurs du marché aux
poissons ont baissé le rideau ce soir
faute de marchandises sur place stéphane
despinoy benoît jourdain
demain il n'y aura pas besoin de verser
de la glace pilée sur le poisson les
derniers poissons ont été emballés cet
après midi au marché de sceaux m cela
fait quelques jours que le marché
d'intérêt national tourne au ralenti il
va maintenant s'arrêter
on est à 20 % du tonnage habituel en
avant nous on a rien à noter
habituellement six chalutiers 17 petits
bateaux alimente la criée mais ils sont
à quai à marseille les toutes dernières
sol et autres casio et saumon négocier
proviennent de boulogne-sur-mer où ont
été importés par solidarité avec les
pêcheurs les mareyeurs ont donc décidé
de baisser le rideau avec la crise du
gazole c'est toute la filière qui temps
si ça perdure tard être très grave pour
nous parce que déjà que la profession ne
marchait pas trop bien
si on se trouve pour nous ici nous avons
une vingtaine d'employés bon si on n'a
pas le produit pour pouvoir faire
rentrer un peu de recettes et
ça sera très très très très mal une
criée sans poissons des étals de
supermarchés vidés pour éviter parfois
les opérations musclées le bras de fer
des pêcheurs ne mollit pas et le
mouvement pourrait cette fois
effectivement faire tache d'huile en
europe des représentants italiens
portugais et espagnols appellent à une
grève illimitée à partir de mercredi et
les pêcheurs de catalogne n'ont pas
attendu ce mot d'ordre ils ont cessé le
travail dès ce matin
on en vient à faire de draguignan le
gendarme soupçonné d'avoir tué un évadé
a été mise en examen la nuit dernière
mise en examen pour coups ayant entraîné
la mort et non pas pour homicide
volontaire comme cela avait été évoqué
au départ la nuit dernière qui a été
marquée par de nouveaux incidents devant
le palais de justice olivier théron
verger llado
la mère et la soeur de joseph vernet
reviennent se constituer partie civile
elles veulent connaître les causes et
les circonstances exactes de cette garde
à vue qui a mal tourné l'élément capital
ce sera l'autopsié du corps criblé de
trois balles qui a été ordonné hier soir
à draguignan la tension était vive entre
gens du voyage jeunes dracénois et
gendarmes mobiles en attendant la mise
en examen du gendarme pour coups et
blessures ayant entraîné la mort de
voitures ont été renversées un peu
allumé les gendarmes mobiles ont chargé
lors de l'évasion tragique le gendarme a
affirmé au juge d'instruction qu'il a
agi en respectant les règles qu'il n'y a
pas eu de bavure le gendarme bien que
tenus sous surveillance n'a pas en
détention provisoire c'est seulement
jeudi que le juge de la liberté et de la
détention se prononcera pour beaucoup de
gendarmes une mise en détention de leurs
collègues pourraient entraîner une
mobilisation
il est tout à fait possible qu'il y ait
des mouvements peut-être dans le style
de ceux de 2001 pourquoi pas avoir
déposé les armes et les cartes
d'officier de police judiciaire dans les
compagnies de gendarmerie
les gens du voyage de l'autre côté
réclame la détention provisoire du
gendarme sa libération au moment des
obsèques de voavy gerner serait perçu
comme une insulte alors on l'entend les
gendarmes protestent contre cette
incarcération de leurs collègues il
estime qu'il n'a fait que respecter la
loi qu'en est il exactement
est il autorisé de tirer sur un homme
après sommation dans de telles
circonstances éléments de réponse avec
audrey goutard et alain du bas
près de dix coups de feu groupe et des
tirs pour tuer c'était en 2003 lors d'un
contrôle routier le conducteur ne
s'était pas arrêtée à temps un gendarme
a tiré là ce sont des voleurs de
voitures surpris par les militaires
bilan un mort et un blessé parmi les
voleurs seuls les gendarmes ont ce droit
de tirer même si aucune vie n'est
menacée une exception au regard de la
loi
ouvre moi et même la police sommes
soumis à la même règle celle qui régit
la légitime défense on ne peut riposter
à une agression que si notre vie ou
celle d'autrui est menacée s'il n'y a
pas d'autre choix si l'action est
proportionnée à l'attaqué pour les
gendarmes la règle est beaucoup plus
souple pourquoi ont-ils ce droit c'est
un décret qui remonte à 1903 à une
époque où la gendarmerie remplis c'est
essentiellement des missions militaires
le texte est clair le gendarme peut
tirer après avoir crié sans succès alc
gendarmerie mais aujourd'hui cela paraît
obsolète à de nombreux professionnels
dans une société d'aujourd'hui c'est un
texte qui peut choquer parce que c'est
un texte militaire fait au début du
xxème siècle dans une société qui n'est
plus la société pacifiée d'aujourd'hui
même la justice semble se ranger à cet
avis alors quelle évolution dans un
arrêt rendu en 2003 la cour de cassation
a restreint usage des armes pour les
gendarmes à moins d'une absolue
nécessité
résultats et fait rarissime un gendarme
doit bientôt passer en cour d'assises
pour avoir tiré sur un fugitif
un cas de conscience maintenant faut-il
graciée jean charles marchiani l'ancien
préfet du var s'est constitué prisonnier
tout à l'heure à la maison d'arrêt de la
santé à paris il a été condamné à des
peines de prison ferme dans deux
affaires de commissions occultes a
condamné qui est aussi un héros pour
beaucoup c'est le cas notamment des
anciens otages français du liban dont il
a contribué à la libération pour eux il
est inenvisageable d'oublier ses états
de service dominique verdeilhan mattioni
vencovsky
jean charles marchiani un homme de
longues que la justice a jeté en pleine
lumière aujourd'hui incarcéré pour
purger une peine de quatre ans de prison
pour avoir touché des commissions
occultes s'élevant à plus de 3 millions
d'euros escroc corrompus jean charles
marchiani n'a jamais supporté cette
étiquette je crois avoir depuis 42 ans
servi mon pays dans l'honneur et la
dignité et je ne pense pas mériter ce
genre de peine car il ya un autre
marchiani celui qui fut préfet du var
celui qui fut l'homme de confiance de
charles pasqua au ministère de
l'intérieur celui surtout qui en 88 a
contribué à la libération des otages du
liban marqué ni celui à qui les plus
hautes autorités de l'état disent merci
le 24 avril dernier nicolas sarkozy se
montraient réticents à l'idée de gracier
jean charles marchiani à l'étranger
parce que qu'est ce qu'on me demande la
justice s'est prononcée et on dit allez
rayer d'un trait de plume ce que la
justice vient de décider séparés mais
pour les ex otages du liban il faut
sauver le soldat marchiani ce soir
marcel carton s'indigne de cette
incarcération
c'est un homme sensationnel on peut pas
l'oublier
c'est grâce à lui mais méconnue de feu
nuit et tout ça il a risqué sa ville au
en octobre prochain jean charles
marchiani sera un nouveau jugé pour la
faire des ventes d'armes à l'angola
à l'étranger d'abord le séisme en chine
une première équipe de secouristes
français est à pied d'oeuvre là bas dit
ainsi cela paraît naturel de fait
c'était encore inimaginable il ya
quelques années pour les hommes de la
sécurité civile c'est une première mais
pas toujours simple l'adaptation se fait
peu à peu envoyés spéciaux samah soula
tristan le braz
habitué à débarquer dans les premières
heures les secours français n'ont été
admis que deux semaines après le séisme
dans un contexte de crise entre les deux
pays mission délicate se rendre utile en
oeuvre lundi bousculer
les vols intérieurs comme ça
on peut l'envoyer là bas
très vite l'équipe française réalise que
l'hôpital maîtrise parfaitement la
situation et qu aucune affectation de là
tant il faut dire qu accepter une telle
aide occidentale et inédit pour la chine
même si l'accueil et courtois pour moi
ce n'est pas de l'affichage passe que
très concrètement nos équipes sont là
parce que les deux premiers jours il ya
un aspect très peut-être diplomatique
moral à je ne sais pas comment on peut
le qualifier qui à mon avis est très
important c'est ce qu'on est en train de
jouer en mal d'activité les urgentistes
se voient proposer d'intégrer l'unité de
soins intensifs
problème il y à déjà quatre médecins
pour 4 passion
l'a frustré là on essaye de d'aider au
mieux et email
les soignants français sont enfin
sollicité l'hôpital évacue ses blessés
pour faire de la place en cas de
violente réplique
ils suivent le mouvement sans en
connaître les détails
on se passe dans les sous dans leur
ambulance
direction la gare un train sanitaire
doit transporter des centaines de
blessés à tianjin à plus de 2000
kilomètres l'impressionnante opération
dure que quelques minutes
français et chinois unis au chevet des
blessés une image largement diffusée par
les médias nationaux
le qu'une aide humanitaire la présence
ici de ce détachement de la sécurité
civile est un symbole diplomatique fort
il signe le début de l'apaisement des
relations franco chinoises mises à mal
par la question du tibet et sur place
les secours libre une autre bataille
pour éviter que les inondations
alourdissent encore un bilan qui se
monte maintenant à 80 et 8000 morts et
disparus les lacs qui se sont formés
lors du séisme menace de céder d'un coup
près de 2000 soldats et policiers au et
policiers sont par exemple arrivé ici
près de beichuan pour dégager les débris
à la dynamite et tenter d'écouler l'eau
peu à peu par ailleurs c'est à noter
devant la colère des familles les
autorités ont réaffirmé que les
responsables d'éventuelles lacunes dans
la construction des écoles dévasté
seraient punis toujours à l'étranger un
voyage français une mission pourrait-on
dire dans la république démocratique du
congo pour aider le pays à préserver la
seconde forêt tropicale du monde après
l'amazonie le ministre de l'écologie
jean louis borloo et son vis-à-vis ont
signé une déclaration commune envoyés
spéciaux nicolas chateauneuf océan
grenier
c'est la deuxième plus grande forêt
tropicale au monde grande comme trois
fois la france en république
démocratique du congo cette immense
étendue est encore largement intact mais
les choses évoluent très vite dans l'un
des pays les plus pauvres du monde 40
des 60 millions d'habitants il puise
tout simplement leur nourriture et leur
bois de chauffe
l'impact est énorme mais sans eau ni
électricité pas toujours facile de
parler de protection de l'environnement
nous disons oui très bien mais quel est
le nôtre contrepartie par rapport à cet
effort par rapport à une administration
qui doit contrôler qui doit fonctionner
par rapport à la population qui préserve
la forêt qu'est ce que la communauté
internationale est prête à prendre en
charge de l'autre côté de la frontière
au congo certains commencent à se
préoccuper de la forêt un trésor de vix
de diversité que découvre jean louis
borloo sur une exploitation forestière
qui fait aujourd'hui figure de modèle ce
que l'abattage n'est pas maîtrisée c'est
un risque pour la batteur puisqu'on ne
maîtrise pas la position de chute ici
chaque parcelle est étudiée exploiter de
manière raisonnée chaque arbre est
soigneusement sélectionnés
pour laisser aux autres spécimens le
temps de grandir
après la coupe le bois est marquée
certifiée par un label écologique
un argument que les consommateurs en
europe ne prennent pas souvent compte on
va soutenir comme présidence française
de l'union qu'on appelle le processus
flec tu sers la traçabilité des
différents poids on appelle le
consommateur à l'extrême vigilance
sur l'exploitation 5000 pygmées vivent
en pleine forêt la société leur a donné
un appareil qui leur permet de marquer
par gps leurs arbres sacrés et ce dont
ils se nourrissent
mais dans le bassin du congo ce souci de
ménager à la fois la forêt et les
populations locales fait encore figure
d'exception
l'immense forêt tropicale du congo
possède des essences de bois extrêmement
recherchés l'industrie forestière
devrait donc se développer dans les
prochaines années et si rien n'est fait
certains experts estiment que la forêt
tropicale pourrait perdre 40 % de sa
superficie d'ici 2050
le salon européen de l'aviation
d'affaires à genève c'est un bon
thermomètre de la croissance mondiale
malgré la flambée des cours du pétrole
le marché ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée grâce aux nouveaux milliardaires
des pays émergents numéro un mondial le
groupe dassault nos envoyés spéciaux ont
suivi l'avionneur français sur place
gera griesbeck tianwan
à 83 ans serge dassault par encore à
l'assaut de nouveaux marchés dans un
avion d'assaut bien sûr avec lui le pdg
charles edelstenne qui dirige le groupe
depuis l'an 2000 direction genève où se
tient le salon européen de l'aviation
d'affaires
aujourd'hui la vedette c'est bien sûr
serge dassault plus à l'aise ici loin
des tracas de sa mairie de corbeil
essonnes
qui n'arrête pas des packs de logements
jeu pas de travail l'ehpad maya
j'ai passé 6 oh la la bon c'est toujours
comme ça on n'a pas refait ma rue on n'a
pas refait reçu que l'école mal foutu
des avions alors
il peut être de bonne humeur serge
dassault il vient de vendre 20 falcon à
une compagnie américaine pour 700
millions de dollars ce salon de genève
ne connaît pas la crise grâce aux hommes
d'affaires russes indiens ou chinois
dans ce lieu si feutré on rencontre
aussi des marchands d'art
alors qu'ils m'ont raconté beau dans le
nucléaire au fond de la mine d'uranium
car dassault est aussi une usine de
guerre qui n'arrive toujours pas à
exporter son avion rafale critiqué même
par le ministre de la défense hervé
morin il a défenseur importe un jugement
un peu rapide parce que il ne sait pas
encore le domaine etc avec maintenant
qu'il a été bien briefé par ses troupes
au sol
qui sait ce que c'est exactement il est
totalement d'accord sur la définition
des données même si on le sent agacé par
les bourdes des hommes politiques
l'industriel ne dira rien de plus ce
soir il reçoit sous bonne garde ses
meilleurs clients loin des regards
indiscrets
en bref une française devient princesse
au danemark elle s'appelle marie
cavallier elle a 32 ans elle a épousé le
prince joachim la cérémonie s'est
déroulée en présence de 300 invités et
avec quelques larmes les deux époux se
sont rencontrés à genève retour en
france avec un drôle de printemps dans
le sud ouest une partie de la dordogne
et du lot-et-garonne est sous les eaux
suite aux inondations lionel feierstein
le boulanger l'a échappé belle hier soir
le torrent boueux et passer juste sous
ses fenêtres
a dit sentiment de la fenêtre
on dira envoyée
pourquoi l'homme à mi hauteur de la
portière avocats dont ce village de
cadouin en dordogne la montée des eaux a
surpris tous les habitants qui n'avait
encore jamais connu de telles
intempéries
toutes les caves du centre ont été
inondées hier soir les commerçants et
les habitants se disaient désemparés
environ cinquante maisons totalement
sinistré quatre commerces pour nous
c'est une catastrophe les pompiers sont
intervenus à 300 reprises dans la région
ils ont travaillé toute la nuit pour
aider les habitants à déblayer
ce matin certaines routes étaient encore
inondées le trafic ferroviaire a été
fortement perturbé dans le sud ouest la
situation devrait progressivement
revenir à la normale d'ici à demain et
knotek météo france émet un bulletin de
vigilance orange à partir de ce soir 22h
sur la corse-du-sud des vents violents
sont attendus jusqu'à 130
kilomètres/heure prudence donc si vous
séjournez là bas les sciences avec le
succès de la mission américaine phoenix
la sonde s'est posé en douceur sur mars
tout près du pôle nord objectif prélever
de la glace et pourquoi pas on peut
rêver trouver des traces d'une vie
passée patrice paul et olivier ponthus
ce
après dix mois de voyage et 700 millions
de kilomètres parcourus on a fêté cette
nuit à la nasa à pasadena en californie
mais aussi à la cité des sciences à
paris le bel exploit de la sonde phoenix
elle s'est posée en douceur près du pôle
nord de mars 1 amar si sage parfait pour
tenter de découvrir dans le sol glacé
des traces de vie on sait qu'il y à de
la glace dans le proche le sol à
quelques centimètres et on va pouvoir
sortir une grande pelle mécanique c'est
le l'objectif finniste et commencer à
creuser et gratter jusqu'à la glace et
essayer de l'analyser voici les
premières images de la région de vingt
six tasses boréalis à un territoire
inhospitalier sans relier des images qui
n'ont mis que 15 minutes pour arriver
sur terre à la villette pour assister au
spectacle
plusieurs centaines de passionnés
s'étaient donné rendez-vous dans le hall
d'accueil tous ont patienté jusqu'à 2
heures du matin
cette bonne occasion de
ce faire les découvertes phoenix n'a
qu'une durée de vie de trois mois pour
trouver des traces de vie les
échantillons de glace vieux de 3
milliards d'années qui vont être
prélevés lèveront peut-être le mystère
la mort de la doyenne des français à
l'âge de 113 ans clémentine solignac
c'était un tiers tranquillement en
présence de sa famille dans sa maison de
retraite de vorey sur arzon en haute
loire à quelques kilomètres de l'endroit
où elle était née en
1894 clémentine solignac avait vécu seul
jusqu'à 106 en tennis c'est la déception
française du jour à roland garros
richard gasquet a déclaré forfait pour
blessure autre déception la pluie qui a
privé les spectateurs de plusieurs
rencontres julien benedetto chloé le
compte
voilà qui ne va pas arranger l'étiquette
de champion fragile qui lui colle à la
peau trente minutes d'échauffement ce
matin avec son nouvel entraîneur et
richard gasquet jette l'épongé une heure
avant son premier tour le numéro un
français souffre d'un kyste au genou
très touché par les critiques ces
derniers temps il ne veut pas prendre le
risque de s'exposer à la vindicte
populaire en cas de défaite encore un
coup dur dans une saison jusqu'ici
décevante ça me frustre tout simplement
pour pouvoir jouer à roland garros
devant tout ce public devant tous les
supporteurs j'adore j'adore vont à jouer
ici à paris cette ambiance
je suis énormément énormément déçu
s'associant
la fragilité de gasquet tranche avec la
sérénité de rodger federer dans son tour
de chauffe le numéro un mondial dominant
3 7 sam querrey un américain allergique
à la terre battue
presque un pléonasme
côté français de qualification de serra
llodra et nicolas devilder 148e mondial
à 28 ans ce gaucher écume tout au long
de l'année le circuit secondaire peu
lucratif issu des qualifications
il élimine en trois sets l'australien
guccione et empoche déjà un chèque de
23000 euros en un tournoi il double ses
gains de l'année le gros lot ce serait
de battre nadal au 2e tour gros match
très difficile donc bon je vais profiter
du moment et puis et puis voilà on verra
ce que je suis ce que je ferai comme un
lion en cage
le triple tenant du titre piaffent
d'impatience dans les vestiaires mais la
pluie s'est invitée à roland garros en
fin d'après midi donnant à son
adversaire brésilien un jour de répit
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle deux des principaux titres
l'euphorie et la cohue de retour dans
leur collège les élèves acteurs de la
palme d'or décernée hier ont été fêtés
comme des vedettes les cours reprennent
normalement demain pour tout le monde et
puis nicolas sarkozy veut pousser les
entreprises à relancer le pouvoir
d'achat il annonce des crédits d'impôt
pour favoriser l'intéressement et des
sanctions financières contre les patrons
qui ne négocie pas les salaires c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo laurent
romejko avec une france coupée en deux
20h50 fbi portés disparus 23h10
complément d'enquêté autour de benoît
duquesne prise d'otage contrebande le
temps des pirates à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr